welcome back everyone this is part four
in our series on presenting your work
this is the final screencast in the
series we're going to be talking about
giving talks especially the sort of talk
that you might give at an NLP Workshop
or conference
I should say at the start that I'm going
to give a lot of advice about how to
give effective talks but the only advice
that I feel really confident in is that
you should cultivate your own style as a
speaker and you should do that by giving
talks and then really and truly
reflecting on how it went looking for
ways you could do better and then
heading off in that direction the
precise direction that you go is highly
individual this will depend on your
goals and your preferences and the style
you're cultivating
but I can promise that if you do this
act of self-reflection you will become a
better speaker it can be painful but it
is very productive and this also means
that the advice that you do here about
giving effective talks should always be
filtered through this highly personal
thing that you're trying to do
that said let's dive in I'm going to
offer a bunch of advice
the first piece of advice I think is
pretty straightforward for the kind of
academic talks that we're talking about
it's a good default to assume that the
talk structure should mirror the paper
structure but the talk needs to be much
simpler you absolutely cannot convey all
the detail that you packed into a paper
it's just the wrong mode for that so
what you can really hope for is that you
find a way of talking about the ideas
that conveys their Essence teaches the
core lessons and entices people to
actually invest in all of the details
that are in your paper
to do that just as with the paper I
think you should open with context
setting what problem are you solving why
is it important and what's been tried
before and why does it fall short and if
you do this context setting right the
audience will be really well set up to
understand the essence of the talk
that's the middle part you should do
concrete details like what are the data
what are the metrics things like that
what's the task structure but really
what you want to do is make sure that
you convey the essence of your idea what
is your approach if it's a model or a
metric or a task structure or something
else this is where you really shine a
light on those ideas and that should
feel like the essence of The Talk The
ideas behind your work
having done that you can kind of add
some quantitative results to support
what you did you can talk about ablation
studies and do error analyzes and so
forth it can kind of Branch out from
their assuming that you've done the job
of really conveying the approach and
then finally at the end you'll want to
quickly summarize but also think ahead
to the Future this is your opportunity
to convey to people how they might build
on the ideas what the important open
questions are and why the work was
ultimately significant
Jeff Pullum has what he calls golden
rules for giving talks he says there are
five of them but they're actually six I
like all these rules I especially like
five and six but I thought I would offer
all of them to you the first one is
don't ever begin with an apology I think
this is reasonable I think the concern
here is that if you start by apologizing
for how bad the talk is going to be
because you didn't prepare or whatever
people might believe you their
impression of you might be that in fact
you're about to give a very bad talk and
that could cause them to check out and
it could certainly shape their opinions
of the talk they do here so start strong
instead of starting with an apology
don't ever underestimate the audience's
intelligence I think the spirit of this
is that we've already baked in that
we're going to give a simple version of
the ideas we're trying to teach a Core
lesson and with that in mind you want to
approach the audience as peers people
who might surprise you with new ideas
but certainly people who are equipped to
understand what you're trying to do and
if you're in that mode I think everyone
will feel good and feel connected around
what you're trying to do
respect the time limits this is nice and
concrete and this is absolutely crucial
it is tragic when people use up all
their time doing context setting and
they never get described to describe
their idea the way to respect the time
limits is to do a lot of practice I
think there is no shortcut here you
should practice you should watch
yourself practicing and you should find
a way to fit the ideas in in a way that
does what you want to do if you don't
practice you are at serious risk of
going way past the time limits
don't survey the whole damn field this
aligns well with the advice I gave
before what you want to do is provide
context for your ideas but it should be
just the context we need in order to
understand the essence of what you've
done and if you cast The Net too widely
people will get lost and you might
simply run out of time
and this one I really like remember that
you're an advocate not the defendant the
spirit of this is like you're a lawyer
and you're defending the ideas you're
invested in doing a good job but you
yourself are not on trial in any sense
uh and so this is like the right level
of investment it's not so personal but
you are of course trying to do the best
thing that you can by the ideas that
you're presenting
and then finally expect questions that
will floor you on the assumption that
you're talking to peers very intelligent
people you've prepared for the
discussion section we'll talk about that
a bit later but even having done that
surprising things can happen that's part
of the reason that we're giving talks
for the exploratory aspect to learn new
things so you should expect questions
that were that are surprising and hard
to resolve maybe questions that even
terrify you that should be considered
part of the exploratory educational
thing that you are doing
on top of all of that I really like to
return to Patrick Blackburn's
fundamental insight about talks I
mentioned this before in the context of
writing Blackburn intended it to be
about talks it applies everywhere he
asks where do good talks come from and
he says honesty a good talk should never
stray far from simple honest
communication I like to think that of
this in the context of Education the
goal of the talk is not to broadcast
ideas or to advertise but rather to
educate and if you approach it from the
perspective of genuinely trying to teach
your ideas to your audience I think
you'll be in the right place you'll
connect with them and they'll take those
further steps of checking out the paper
and more deeply understanding what
you've done
people joke about PowerPoint and they
worry about the kind of distorting
effects that it can have on the way we
present our ideas I think it's
reasonable to be a bit worried but
obviously I'm not too worried because
this entire course is based in
screencasts where I'm using slides
PowerPoint style things
but we do need to be thoughtful about
how we use this device
as you read about advice for talks you
see kind of two camps emerge the
minimalist and the comparative the
minimalist view is that your slide
should be as spare as possible the
audience should spend most of the time
listening to you and looking at you
individual slides don't stay up for long
and they don't get used in more than one
way they're kind of just punctuation to
the talk track
you could compare that with the
comparative view your slide should be as
full as possible without sacrificing
Clarity your talk should make it easy
for people to spend time studying your
slides individual slides stay up for a
long time and get used to make multiple
comparisons and establish numerous
connections
I'll talk a little bit in a second about
how I think these approaches compare to
each other how this relates to style and
to your goals the one thing I will say
here now
is that whatever your Camp is this slide
is making a colossal mistake the mistake
it makes is that I put all the
information up all at once and I know
that that means that for the most of the
time that I was talking a lot of you
were reading around on the slide and we
got disconnected what I should have done
is show you the information in the order
I presented it so that you were with me
as I was giving my talk track whether
the slide is simple or complex I feel
like that has to be good advice because
this is a lot about joint attention
but whether you're a minimalist or
comparativist is really going to be a
personal matter the minimalist view
seems right to me for telling a story
it's often the best mode when time is of
the essence and the audience is mainly
there to learn at a high level about
what your paper contains whereas the
comparative view seems right to me for
teaching it's the closest slides come to
a full well-organized chalkboard and
good advice for a chalkboard is that you
never erase things until you absolutely
have to because you might need them
later same thing with a slide if you can
get a lot of information up there when
it's still perspicuous then you'll have
lots of chances to do comparisons answer
questions and fundamentally to educate
find the style that works for you though
as long as you think long and hard about
what it will be like to listen to your
talk and you make adjustments you'll
shine you will become a better speaker
in whatever mode you feel is a good way
for you
guiding audience attention is crucial
though that's the joke that I made
before about my over full slide with no
overlays use overlays to fill a slide
while still keeping the audience with
you this is how you can be a
comparativist while not losing the
attention of the audience
color used systematically to create
distinctions is wonderful as long as
you're sure that the colors really do
create contrast that will survive color
blindness from your audience members and
also really poor projectors which can be
quite a problem
size is great to draw attention to
things boxes arrows and other devices
help people navigate plots especially
model diagrams long Pro statements and
so forth it's incredibly helpful to put
boxes around the part of a results table
or the part of a model diagram that you
are talking about in the order that you
talk about it so that people know
exactly where to look as you make your
crucial points these devices are
absolutely wonderful in the minimalist
mode I mode I guess you would say
overlays color size boxes arrows I
honestly find this really hard to track
a lot of the time I understand that it's
kind of dynamic feeling but you can tell
in the way I'm talking that I am more of
a comparativist than a minimalist when
it comes to slides
let's wrap up with some more mundane
things turn off notifications that might
appear on your screen if you get up in
front of thousands of people at an ACL
conference to give an important talk
it's your moment to shine you do not
want personal messages flashing by as
notifications in the upper corner of
your screen shut those down
make sure your computer is out of power
save mode so that the screen doesn't
shut down while you're talking the most
tragic thing here is that you step away
from the computer to make a point you're
doing that long enough that the screen
shuts down and then the projector won't
come back and you lose many minutes of
your allotted time just trying to get
the projector to cooperate so sad just
make sure your screen doesn't do that
and you'll be better off
shut down running applications that
might get in your way they could eat up
memory and cause problems or they could
just start to ask that you update them
or some other needy thing right in the
middle of the talk and it could distract
everyone and you might not notice the
little bouncing icon that everyone is
now studying instead of listening to you
make sure your desktop is clear of files
and notes that you wouldn't want the
world to see again imagine you're up in
front of thousands of people they are
definitely going to study whatever they
can see of your desktop as they sit idly
waiting for your talk to start or
whatever else is happening make sure
that's information that you want
everyone to be looking at
and if you're using PowerPoint or
keynote or Google Slides or some
specialized software that might depend
on having net access make a PDF backup
so that it's there just in case and
really the ultimate in survival here
projectors can fail so you should be
prepared to give the talk without any
slides the audience will be on your side
if you have to do this it's a real
opportunity to shine be ready to do it
as a talk track alone
and then finally the discussion period
this is often the most anxiety producing
part of giving any talk it's very
important it should be the chance for
the audience to gain a deeper
understanding of your ideas and when
that is the spirit of the audience this
is wonderful you really feel like you're
engaged in a new kind of exploration and
education
sometimes though other things do happen
hostile questioners confused questioners
people who won't give up the floor all
of that other stuff that can be so
anxiety producing
you have to live with that when people
ask questions my standard advice is to
pause for a second before answering each
one if you can possibly help it that
will make sure that they're done talking
and it will also make you appear
deliberative and I think that's always
good in terms of honoring the
contributions people make I grant that
you've thought about the ideas forever
you might know what answer you want to
give from word one from this person but
at least keep up the pretense that you
are actively listening you might be
surprised and also you want to honor the
contributions of these people
avoid saying I have no idea and leaving
it at that you can probably get away
with doing that once if it's a really
blazing Insight but ideally you say
something like I have no idea but let's
think in this direction or let's
meditate on this possible extension or
whatever it is to create a discourse
again because that's after all the goal
of these things
most questions won't make total sense to
you
've thought about the ideas a lot your
questioner may be entirely new to them
and they might be struggling as part of
their question to figure out exactly how
to come to grips with the ideas so you
have to work with that and find a way
for this to feel productive you'll be a
hit if you can warp every question
whether confused or not hostile or not
whatever it is into one that makes sense
and leaves everyone with the impression
that the questioner raised an important
issue then everyone will feel validated
you'll feel like you've connected with
people and they'll feel like they
connected with you
notice that I have called this the
discussion period it's often called The
Q a period I think that's a misnomer
it's really not about question and
answer it's about discussion and if you
ease into that mode I think you overall
feel more satisfied by these these
experiences recognizing though that
sometimes they kind of do go off the
rails